his name is Willie Jay Parker and he's
an OBGYN he's often the author of a new
book life's work all about the joy of
being an abortionist and now he's the
subject of a fawning New York Times
interview Parker used to oppose abortion
but now he's for it why the answer isn't
really clear but we're supposed to
sympathize with him because he clearly
wants to help women here is Parker's
explanation for his shift from pro-life
to pro-abortion quote I had come to a
crisis moment regarding a religious
understanding that left me unable to
help women when I felt deeply for their
situation I needed to convert from a
religious understanding that left me
paralyzed to act on my deepest sense of
connection to one that empowered me to
do what I felt to be the right thing in
other words leave got behind I have a
better system so go for it there's
actually kind of disgusting to compare
the ideological movement from not
killing babies to killing babies to a
religious conversion and the notion that
this guy felt bad because he couldn't
help women who wanted abortion and thus
abortion had to be correct that's the
license can come in all sorts of moral
atrocities you feel bad for the woman
whose husband's kind of a jerk so you go
and kill him but here's the amazing
thing
Parker admits this doctor admits that
abortion is a life-ending process he
says quote if I thought I was killing a
person I wouldn't do abortions a fetus
is not a person it is a human entity so
it's a quasi human which means that it
should have quasi human rights even by
that logic no not according to Parker he
thinks so long as you're not fully human
by his vague definition you have no
rights whatsoever and you can be killed
for the sake of convenience he says
quote in the moral scheme of things I
don't hold fetal life and the life of a
woman equally I value them both but in
the precedence of things when a woman
comes to me I find myself unable to
demote her aspirations because of the
aspirations that someone else has for
the fetus that she's carrying again this
is pretty gross he doesn't value them
both if he did he put some sort of
conditions on the termination of what he
calls fetal life instead he just says
that a woman's desire for a promotion at
work outranks some Outsiders aspirations
for her fetus but what about the fetuses
aspirations is the value of a baby's
future truly just subjective what if the
baby is already born the mother wants to
kill it shouldn't outsiders the
aspirations for the baby now Trump the
mothers desire or no Parker talks about
making abortion easy for women using his
rhetoric to a near women to any sort of
emotional struggle he calls this
creepily enough verba Kane seriously he
then says that elite white women are
responsible for people worrying about
abortion and that's you guess it ray
there's what he says quote when women
acquiesce to a rule determined primarily
by their biology of reproduction even if
it's unconsciously they judge each other
for rejecting that primary identity so
if you think and the most essential role
for a woman is to procreate and humanity
doesn't go on unless you do that then
anything to interrupt that process is to
be counterintuitive or immoral the
biggest insult to the notion there's
such a thing as black that there's such
a thing as black genocide as it's the
people who care about abortion really
care about black women and black babies
well people who don't want to tell black
babies in the womb care more about black
babies by definition than dr. Parker but
when you're talking with the New York
Times it's always convenient to pull the
race card it's also worth noting here
that women are not acquiescing to some
sort of arbitrarily defined societal
role when they talk about the value of
motherhood this is called biology the
perpetuation of the human race occurs
because women get pregnant and have
babies you see this as some sort of
curse rather than the greatest blessing
on the planet makes you kind of a sick
human being Parker finally compares
pro-lifers to slavery flavors that
people often struggle with why I as a
man and deeply committed to feminism
reproductive justice and gender equality
I come from a heritage of people who
know what it's like to have your life
controlled by somebody else but truly if
Parker really wanted to talk about a
working analogy to slavery you should
probably start with what he does every
day deny the personhood of another human
being for convenience and profit and
treat that person instead as property to
be discarded if parker is truly worried
about controlling the lives of others
perhaps you should stop ending them I'm
Ben Shapiro this is Ben Shapiro show
ah okay so here we are we have a lot to
get through today we have a chock-full
mailbag when gets all that plus is from
fighting with his own Supreme Court
nominee is Trump trying to use the power
of the White House to make people by
Ivanka Trump stuff huh no we'll get to
that in just one second but first we
have to say thank you to our advertisers
over at wink it's spelled winc this is
the line company we've talking been
talking to you about for a while you go
to their website over at tribe wing calm
try winc calm flash fun and what they do
is they give you a sort of survey what
kinds of tastes you like what kind of
pace you don't
and then they recommend wine free so if
you know nothing about wine like me and
you want to get a great wine then you go
to try blink calm slash Ben and then you
go through the survey and they provide
you a recommendation for one that is
top-notch everybody in the office has
had this one this is why they're drunk
off their butts half the time and they
say that it is really first-class line
it's also really really affordable line
and they send it directly to you and you
go to try Winx comm it's they used to be
called Club W now it's called Winx so if
you've tried quad double you know how's
that it is if not then go to tribe Winx
comm winc dot-com / friend by the way if
you don't like the bottle that they send
you you can try it and then you can talk
them they'll send you another one if you
don't like the bottle and you think that
it didn't match what you're looking for
so it's a pretty foolproof guarantee
they have 100% satisfaction guarantee
try wink comm / Ben and get $20 off if
you use the slash pen so make sure you
do that lets them know that we sent you
and also make sure that you get that $20
off which is a couple of wine bottles if
you actually use that credit so $20 off
when you go to try blink calm it / bed
and they cover they cover all of the
shipping okay so we begin today with
Donald Trump and it's not been a good 24
hours for president Trump it hasn't and
we'll get to Elizabeth Warren and all of
all of the sexist nonsense coming out of
the media in just a second but it's been
a bad 24 hours for Trump because he just
can't control himself and you knew
sooner or later this is going to get
them in trouble turns out it sooner
rather than later because at the
beginning and concern of masses is
personal deficiencies with the fact that
on policy Trump's been pretty good right
picked gorson she puts out these
executive orders and conservatives like
and you think okay
that big deal that he mouthed off a lot
and to certain extent that's true and
then you get a week like this one where
he really hasn't done anything there
haven't been any major executive orders
this week there haven't been any major
policy moves this week it's basically
just been Trump talking and that's most
weeks for the president most weeks for
the president are not replete with
action most weeks for the president are
not filled with executive orders
changing the nature of government most
weeks of the president are the
presidents going back and forth of
Congress in the judiciary and making
policy behind the scenes and talking a
lot and the talking part of the job is
actually kind of important unfortunately
this is the part that Trump is not that
good at so we start today with this
hubbub that is broken out over Nordstrom
so Nordstrom has decided they're no
longer going to carry a falcon Trump's
clothing line I think this is a jerky
move I do I think it's a gross move I
think companies that are dumping about
Trump's clothing lines are really kind
of gross I don't see why you wouldn't
carry a clothing line just because you
don't like the politics of a person's
father even if you don't like the
politics of the person I have kind of
problems with the idea that you're not
going to stop their clothing line and
Nordstrom said that they made this
decision based on performance they said
that the sales of Ivanka Trump products
slid in the last half of the year that's
certainly possible it's possible a lot
of people started not buying a box of
Trump stuff because they didn't like
Trump himself if I owned controls people
say this is not true and so they claim
that this was just discrimination
basically so look private businesses
have the right to do whatever they want
to do with regard to their business if
advance Trump's products are great then
other businesses will stock them and
they will sell and it will be fine do I
think Nordstrom is being stupid about
this yes so I think TJ Maxx is being
stupid TJ Maxx is taking all the Ivanka
Trump labels off of the rack and they're
now stocking Ivanka Trump stuff kind of
alongside all their other stuff I think
that's silly do I think that it's
ridiculous that what was it there's
another one it's some very members at
one of these companies Neiman Marcus
pulled the Ivanka Trump jewelry so I
think that's ridiculous and silly yes I
don't do a buying a necklace has to do
with the vodka Trump maternity leave
policy or anything else that said
Trump's reaction is just brainless it's
just brainless Donald Trump goes on
Twitter when he starts tweeting about
Nordstrom's now it's not unprecedented
for the president to get angry at people
for being mad at his daughter right the
people were passing around a Harry
Truman letter where he went after a
critic because Margaret Truman
was a performer and somebody didn't like
one of her performances and so you
savage the critic that's not quite the
same thing as what Trump is doing here
because here it actually has an impact
on a business he says my daughter Ivanka
has been treated so unfairly by
Nordstrom she is a great person always
pushing me to do the right thing
terrible exclamation point and then
which is odd the President of the United
States Twitter accounts actually
retweeted that so the feeling had been
Trump's personal Twitter account was
going to be for trumpian nonsense and
the president account was going to be
for presidential stuff and not anymore
now he's retweeting that sort of stuff
that was not great then it got worse
okay Sean Spicer comes out and Sean
Spicer starts ranting about Nordstrom so
here is a secretary Spicer I think this
is what I like really my business and an
attack on his daughter he ran for
president he won he's leading this
country and I think for people to take
out their concern about his actions or
his executive orders members of his
family he has every right to stand up
for his family and and applaud their
their their business activities their
success so look when it comes to his
family I think he's been very clear how
proud he is of what they do and what
they've accomplished and for someone to
take out their concern with his policies
on a family member of hurt is it's just
is not acceptable the president has
every right as a father to stand up for
them okay he has every right as a father
to stand up for them the question isn't
as a father as a father what he's doing
is fine as a president the question is
do you have the right to go out there
and start railing on companies because
they're not doing business with your
daughter anymore and it's not just that
Kellyanne Conway then goes on national
television this morning and she says
openly I'm going to basically do an
advertisement for Ivanka Trump's product
and she says go by Ivanka Trump's stuff
is what I would tell you I hate shopping
but I'm going to go get something for
myself today okay look there are plenty
of us out here who would say that
Nordstrom is doing the wrong thing there
are plenty of us out here who would say
go buy advances so I actually agree with
that go buy Ivanka stuff that's not the
point the point is this is not something
that the white house ought to be doing
because this is conflict of interest
you're not supposed to be using the
press secretary of the United States or
Kellyanne Conway the senior
communications advisor you're not
supposed to be using these people in
order to
business for your your daughter or for
your siblings or for yourself okay this
is self dealing and it isn't good
under federal law she may violated
federal law under federal law federal
employees are not supposed to use public
office for endorsements of any
product/service or enterprise or for the
private gain of friends and relatives
none of this is any good if you want
Trump to be good if you want Trump to
have a successful presidency this sort
of nonsense has to stop and this is not
about railing on Trump is not about I
don't like Trump this is about no one
should be doing this imagine for a
second that Hillary Clinton been elected
and she says and people said we're not
sending donations to Chelsea anymore
first of all the right would cheer
second of all if she then came out and
she said I want everyone in the country
to give money to my foundation to
Chelsea's foundation I think people
would be a little upset and they'd have
a right to be upset
in fact we spent most of the last
election cycle talking about conflicts
of interests between the Secretary of
State and the Clinton Foundation to
pretend this doesn't exist when you
stick a tea by the name is just silly so
this is this is ridiculous and Trump
should have engaged himself in this but
that wasn't the only silly thing that
happened okay the others only thing that
happened is the Neel corset who is the
the Trump pick his excellent pick for
the Supreme Court which I have praised
up to Oz who at this point I think from
multiple times for Gorsuch was asked
about Trump attacking the Seattle judge
this is district court judge in
Washington who put a stay on his on his
executive order and Gorsuch according to
multiple sources ranging from Richard
Blumenthal Democrat of Connecticut to
senator Ben Sasse of Nebraska who is a
Republican tore into Trump's attacks on
the judiciary so apparently Gorsuch said
that he didn't like what Trump was doing
this is what staffs told Morning Joe
this morning to Judge Gorsuch and I
actually talked about that and frankly
he got pretty passionate about it I
asked him about the so-called judges
comment because we don't have so-called
judges or so-called presidents or
so-called senators and this is a guy who
kind of welled up with some energy and
he said any attack on any of I think his
term to me was brothers or sisters of
the robe is an attack on all judges
according to Blumenthal Gorsuch called
Trump's attacks disheartening and
demoralizing and then Kelly Ayotte who's
a spokesperson for Neil Gorsuch she said
he said that he finds any criticism of a
judge's integrity and independence
disheartening and demoralizing okay so
we now have three separate sources
including Gorsuch a spokesperson who
said that
Orage said he didn't like Trump's
attacks on the judiciary and mrs. Foley
was in character and so he was in
character for more such gorgeous his
first call after his nomination was who
meat was to be was to Merrick garland
the guy that Obama picked to fill
Scalia's seat because he has a lot of
respect for other members of the
judiciary which i think is probably a
good thing you want the judicial branch
to defend itself you want the executive
branch to defend itself conflict between
the branches is totally fine and yet
there's this whole contingent to people
who announced that gorse a chap to go
terrible oh I don't even know what
course is doing so Laura Ingraham who's
just become a joke of a human I mean
Laura Ingraham who is a very very smart
human being she clerked for a Clarence
Thomas she knows better than this here's
what she tweeted out judge gore such as
comments about Donald Trump's tweets are
concerning judge prior or Hardiman knows
better doesn't bode well doesn't bode
well I missed the part where there's a
provision in article 3 of the
Constitution that says you're not
allowed to disagree with the president
in fact it seems to me one of the chief
qualifications for being on the Supreme
Court is the capacity to disagree with
the president when you think that he's
wrong or violating his duty and it's
just this is silly stuff it's silly
stuff and then Trump because he can't
help himself the problem is not the
Trump attacks the problem is Trump
attack like an idiot so Trump because
Trump then goes on Twitter and he starts
tweeting Senator Richard Blumenthal who
never fought in Vietnam when he said for
years he had major ly now represents
what judge Gorsuch told him Chris Cuomo
in his interview with senator Blumenthal
never asked him about his long term lie
about his brave service in Vietnam all
caps fake news so number one women
thought what Blumenthal said wasn't fake
news it was confirmed by staff and I on
both of whom were in the room that has
nothing to do with Trump Trump was not
there he doesn't know second of all when
Trump goes after he went after a Chris
Cuomo now with him I'm normally fine was
going after Chris Cuomo I think Chris
Cuomo has the IQ of a kumquat but that
doesn't change the fact that Chris Cuomo
did actually ask Richard Blumenthal
about the military service why in fact
it was the very first thing he asked him
in the interview so Trump is just making
a fool of themselves and there's no
reason for this it's very frustrating if
you want the policy to be good and if
you want the policy to be followed up by
excellent rhetoric and verbiage if you
don't want the policy undermined by
stupidity then you should be upset about
this
okay Trump needs to do better he needs
to do better and if he doesn't do better
he's going to be undermining his own
cause we're going to talk a little bit
more about all of that plus the sort of
trust me mentality and we're going to
get to the mailbag we have an epic
mailbag today's you're going to want to
stick around for that but first we have
to say thank you to one of our
advertisers over at Birch gold oh yes so
if you are interested in purchasing
precious metals if you are interested in
investing and diversifying into precious
metals Birch gold is the place for you
they have a long-standing record of
continued success they have thousands of
satisfied clients they have a bunch of
five-star ratings and an A+ rating with
the Better Business Bureau and right now
they have 16 page kit a free kit they'll
send you revealing how gold and silver
can protect your savings and also how
you can move your money from your IRA or
401k out of stock and into precious
metals IRA with no tax consequences so
you're going to want to talk to them at
www.calculated.com/support which given
all the talk about inflating the
currency might be a good idea at this
point you want to talk to my friends
over at Birch gold calm slash Ben so
final note before we before we have to
leave you on YouTube and Facebook all of
this is problem for Trump mainly because
a lot of what Trump is doing now is
reliant Romney trust me phenomenon the
trust me philosophy this idea that if we
just trust him it'll be okay so Sean
Spicer was basically confronted at the
White House press conference with the
fact that Matt Drudge was saying what do
you guys doing about Obama care because
the Republicans haven't touched Obama
care yet and here was Sean Spicer his
response I I could hardly stall and I
think it's a mammoth thing to repeal and
replace I think there's no question the
president's commitment to doing this
you've heard speaker Ryan talk about how
we're going to we should be able have
this wrapped up by the end of the year
it's a big bill
I got jammed through and it was very
sweeping and we'll talk about one fifth
of our economy we can either do it
quickly
as the Democrats did and end up with a
monstrosity where premiums go up access
is limited we can do it right and I
think the president while he wants to
get this done as soon as possible and
understand what's at stake he wants to
do it right he understands down
health care is to American families and
individuals and so his goal is to get it
done right and have an outcome that
achieves the goals that it sets out to
do okay so all of that sounds fine but
it is really a lot of trust me people
are happened to trust crumpets they feel
like he's in control if he's doing silly
things like fighting with his own
Supreme Court pick if he's doing silly
things like using the white house in
order provoke return promote Ivanka's
business it makes it harder to do the
trust me routine a little bit so we're
going to need some more good policy in
order to balance out a lot of bad
rhetoric this week does not been a good
week for president Trump the last two
were good this one was not but we'll get
some more of that you'll have to go over
to Daley wire.com I want to talk about
what the Democrats are doing because
that's fully insane plus we have the
mailbag coming up and you can be part of
the mailbag if you go to Daley wire comm
right now and subscribe eight dollars a
month makes you subscriber right now if
you want an annual subscription you
spend that at same eight dollars a month
and that will allow you to get a free
copy of this terrific DVD of the Arroyo
the Arroyo is a fantastic movie about
what's going on on our southern border
and why the immigration problem is such
a problem the illegal immigration
problems drug cartels on our southern
border so go over to Daley wire calm
right now get that annual subscription
and again that gives you all sorts of
extra benefits I keep promising the
Shapiro store I do promise it is coming
and there will be good stuff in it but
you have to go over and subscribe right
now you are otherwise just go over to
iTunes SoundCloud you can listen to the
rest of its later and and give us a
rating on iTunes because we know that
you love us we are the number one
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]